the coronavirus pandemic is reaching
dramatic new heights in italy
one of the first countries to take
drastic action against a virus in the
spring
now we're in the fall as you know and
covet has returned with a vengeance
there
italy is approaching one million total
cases and the newest outbreaks cover
much more of the country
chris livesay visited an overwhelmed icu
in rome
where doctors fear conditions are on the
verge of exploding
life-saving breaths of air but for
others
their last so this is a patient who just
passed away from clovid19 just this
moment
so just two or three minutes ago this
patient was alive and now he's passed
away
unfortunately it happens says dr
sebastiano petrarca
more and more often as infections are
soaring again across
italy once the worst hit country at the
start of the global pandemic
italy was the first country in the world
to lock down
nationally so that this would never have
to happen
again but now hospitals like these their
intensive care units are on the brink
of running out of beds out of 30 icu
beds
this hospital is down to its last one
rome's covet hospitals are saturated he
says
it's unimaginable and he's afraid their
additional covet floor
rushed to construction won't be ready in
time
a terrifying sign in the capital rome a
city that was largely unscathed in the
first wave of the virus
but italians eventually dropped their
guard says dr petrarca
who now fears a second wave worse than
the first
i'm worried it's exploding again like
what we saw in bergamo in milan
the body count is going to climb he says
the government is now forced to lock
down five high-risk
red zones non-essential businesses
closed
movement outside your hometown forbidden
crucial measures to contain the spread
in italy
says the prime minister just as italy
was a warning to the u.s
earlier this year of worst to come
health officials caution
this latest wave could be yet another
omen
of what's ahead
piazzas like this one are now emptying
around the country as new coveted
restrictions
kick in but it may be too little too
late the head of italy's higher health
institute warns that the entire country
risks running out of icu beds
within one month tony hard to watch it
all unfold again for us
chris livesay in rome thank you very
much